should we stay in Syria or should we go
should we stay or should we go now if we
go there will be trouble and if we stay
it will be double so come on let me know
should we stay or should we go we will
examine president Trump's decision to
relocate US forces in Syria then NBC's
Chuck Todd loses his mind what little he
had left Democrats get caught in more
foreign interference hypocrisy and a
hopeful note from Ellen DeGeneres all
that and more on Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to today but first let's
talk about something really important
forget about that foreign policy pulling
troops out of various countries and
putting them into other countries forget
it let's talk about something important
like eating your fruits and vegetables
have you ever wondered why so many
Americans are sick unhealthy and
overweight why they just they don't look
good they don't feel good they're all
lethargic I'm describing myself I feel I
don't know I'm not saying I don't look
good I just don't feel as fit all the
time as as full of energy as I could
it's cuz I don't get my fruits and
vegetables now there's an easy way to do
it we have a food supply issue in the
u.s. we have a sedentary lifestyle here
Americans are in worse shape than ever
that's why the team of on staff
positions at brickHouse Nutrition
created field of greens field of greens
is an easy way for you to add fruits and
vegetables to your daily routine without
spending hours in the produce section or
hiring a home chef or taking cheap
supplements field of greens is terrific
it is made with real usda organic fruits
and vegetables it also helps boost your
immunity using antioxidants and assists
digestive health with prebiotics and
probiotics it is like having a doctor
and a nutritionist in your kitchen I
really love this stuff because I want it
to be easy if it were just me I would
spend my days eating fatty Italian meats
and provolone cheese and that would be
my entire diet and then I would die so
luckily because of brick as you get one
scoop just one scoop delivers a full
serving of fruits and vegetables you
drop it in a cup of water stir it and
you're done also goes very great with
smoothies bottom line this is real food
this is not extracts you will look and
feel better it's just great I love it
makes it very simple and makes you feel
better Brickhouse Knowles dot-com go to
it you get your own URL how about that
brick house Knowles calm 15% off your
first order just for trying it out with
promo code Knowles brick house Knowles
kena wles calm promo code Knowles my
first question today this is just let me
know your answers let me know in the
chat box and and on Twitter what should
we do in Syria what should we do
everybody seems to have a really strong
opinion about this about what President
Trump should
with our forces in Syria so I just just
right now when you think you've got a
really strong opinion about this and you
know that you're right and you know the
people who disagree with you were wrong
what should we do in Syria what-what
does anybody know about Syria could you
find Syria on a map I I'm not insulting
anybody I don't know that I could find
Syriana map people like to think that
they have so much more knowledge about
foreign policy and the affairs of other
nations than they actually do think
about close your eyes think about Syria
right now then think about all the
countries around Syria what are the cut
can you name the countries around Syria
where is Turkey where in relation to
Syria is - where's Russia where is Iran
where is it's very difficult all of this
stuff it seems so simple in the abstract
it's very complicated and the reality of
it this Syria decision which by the way
is being completely misreported or at
least misunderstood in the in the
popular conscience this Syria decision
is one of those times where people have
a lot more in the way of opinion than
they have in the way of knowledge and I
would bet you if you go on I'm sure
listen if you're listening to this
program you've got an erudite you've got
a really open-minded way of viewing
things but I bet your friends on Twitter
don't your friends on Facebook don't
you're gonna see people posting all
these angry comments and all these
strong opinions probably the stronger
opinion among your friends the less
knowledge they actually have what is the
decision a lot of people are saying
Trump is pulling out of Syria he's not
Trump is not pulling out of Syria
actually do you know how many troops
he's gonna be relocating between 50 and
150 troops not 50,000 not 5,000 not 550
- 150 troops specifically special
operators we have 1,000 troops in Syria
not a huge force we have a thousand
troops in Syria he's going to relocate
50 to 150 troops now that's not nothing
this decision is momentous because Trump
is moving those troops to accommodate a
Turkish invasion Turkey
is going to invade part of northern
Syria and so Trump is moving those
troops these US troops to get the troops
out of the way why does it matter the
turkey is invading part of northern
Syria and Syria is a complete mess so
who cares a turkey invades because
turkey is going to be invading a part of
Syria that is specifically controlled by
the Kurds and the Kurds or us Allied
forces and they have helped the u.s.
fight the war on terror and they've
helped the u.s. in Syria and Turkey
doesn't like the Kurds simple enough so
far it's getting more complicated but
it's simple enough so far now it gets a
little more complicated because the
Kurds who are in it controlling this
area in northern Syria currently also
control tens of thousands of former Isis
fighters and end supporters of Isis yet
tens of thousands of people in camps and
prisons and just areas that they control
so if Turkey invades northern Syria
takes over land that is currently
controlled by the Kurds that has a lot
of former Isis fighters in it that means
Turkey is going to be responsible for
those Isis fighters now you might be
asking yourself why on earth would
anybody want to go into these areas with
all these former Isis fighters that
doesn't seem like a real prize if I'm
looking at real estate I want to go to
Fiji I want to go to Hawaii I don't want
to go to some godforsaken sand desert
where there are a lot of some of the
worst terrorists on earth why do they
want to go in there they want to go in
there because Turkey views the Syrian
Kurdish forces
so those Kurds that are controlling that
part of northern Syria they view those
Syrian Kurdish forces as being tied to
other Kurdish forces who are in Turkey
the Kurdistan Workers Party which is
also known as the PKK I don't know why I
guess I guess in whatever language it's
written in P stands for Kurdistan and K
stands for Workers Party and K stands
for Workers Party
I don't something like that the
Kurdistan Workers Party is the PKK
Turkey considers the PKK to be a
terrorist group and a separatist group
and Turkey has been fighting the
Kurdistan Workers Party for decades and
the Kurdistan Workers Party on
prizing Lee or allied with the Kurdish
forces in Syria okay
now we don't really like being put in
this situation this is a very difficult
situation why because the Kurds have
been helping us for decades decades and
decades before September 11th we had a
relationship with the Kurds and they've
been very good about the war on terror
and they've been very good at
specifically helping us fight Isis so we
like the Kurds we don't want to abandon
the Kurds we don't want Turkey to roll
in and Massacre the Kurds also we have a
relationship with Turkey and our
relationship with Turkey goes back even
further it's very difficult for us to
imagine turkey as some great ally right
now but turkey is in NATO turkey is
official turkey is not just an ally of
ours but they're officially an ally of
ours in NATO now when did turkey enter
NATO wasn't after 9/11 it wasn't just
before 9/11 this was 1952 they've been
in NATO but what is NATO what's the
purpose of NATO NATO was formed to fight
the Soviet Union in the Cold War the
Cold War has been over for decades so
what purpose is NATO serving I guess
it's to stem Russian aggression into the
former Soviet states and so be
controlled areas but what sense does
this make now you are beginning to see
the the problem that we are facing not
just in the Middle East but in our
foreign policy broadly we have two
allies who are going to come into
conflict with one another in northern
Syria the Kurds who are have been
wearing the American flag and fighting
alongside us against Isis and Turkey
which we don't really like very much and
there are in many ways very adversarial
to us but they've been officially a NATO
ally since the 1950s since the early
1950s and NATO might be outdated and
there might not be any reason to have
NATO in the first place all of that put
together which do we privilege the Kurds
or Turkey Kurd the Kurds are better
allies turkey as a more official Ally
and the sad fact of all of this is the
United States does not have permanent or
even enduring relationships with sub
state entities the Kurds are not a
nation there's no there's no nation of
Kurdistan there's
no there's no state rather is what I
meant to say there's no official state
in the nation state system in the United
Nations and the Westphalian system
there's no state called Kurdistan there
is a state called
Turkey and so we privilege our alliance
with turkey over our relationship with
the Kurds who are certainly a coherent
group of people but they are not a
nation state this gets to the biggest
debate of the trump era you can almost
forget all of those details I mean it's
important context to have the this gets
to the biggest debate of the Trump era
it's largely what the 2016 election was
about it's largely what the 2020
election is going to be about it's a
question much larger than Trump or one
or two elections this is a question that
will define the next hundred to five
hundred years of geopolitics and we'll
get to that question in one second but
first I have to thank our friends over
at wise foods wise foods it is very
important to be prepared during an
emergency we've seen things are getting
pretty crazy all around the world and
chaos can take over in just a second
wise company takes an innovative
approach in providing dependable simple
and affordable freeze-dried food for
emergency preparedness and outdoor use
when government resources are strained
it can be days if not weeks before you
can get to fresh food and water you
can't rely on somebody else you can't
rely on the government certainly can't
rely on the government you can rely on
the government least of all you have to
rely on yourself you can't know what
tomorrow may bring but you can have
peace of mind knowing that you will be
ready for it so don't put yourself in a
situation where you need something that
you don't have be prepared today the
thing I love about this because I'm a
man I don't really think about all being
prepared all the time and I just don't
do it and I live live on the wild side
however there's this low level of stress
where you think gosh if a natural
disaster happened or some big political
event I really want sweet little ELISA
be safe I really want my family to be
safe you just get it just get the
emergency food you put it in a pantry
somewhere and you don't have to think
about it and you know that you're
getting the best and you know you're
getting an incredible deal on it and
then it's over and then if you've got to
get out of Dodge someday if the zombie
apocalypse hits you're ready to go
otherwise you have peace of mind you
can't put a price on
this week my listeners can get any wise
emergency or outdoor food product at an
extra 25 percent off the lowest March
price at Weis food storage calm when
entering knowles canto wles at checkout
or by calling eight five five four five
three two nine four five plus shipping
is free wise has a 90 day no questions
asked return policy there is no risk in
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family more prepared today wise
food storage dot-com promo code Knowles
canna wles to get any wise emergency or
outdoor food product and an extra 25%
off and free shipping go do it very
important this whole Syria question and
the Kurds and Turkey and Iran and Russia
which we haven't even really talked
about this gets to the central question
of the Trump era and it's a question
that we've been kicking around since the
end of the Cold War will the United
States be an empire or a nation or we an
empire or a nation do we favor a system
of government around the world that
creates an empire or empires or do we
still favor the Westphalian system of
nation-states which we've had for four
hundred years now what is it neither of
these terms are necessarily bad things
you'll hear people use imperialism which
is just the form of empire they'll use
imperialism or nationalism as
pejoratives as insults as bad terms
you're an imperialist you're a
nationalist neither of those terms are
necessarily bad in a in and of
themselves there have been terrific
empires in the history of the world the
the government that we always kind of
yearned back to in Western civilization
is the Roman Empire the Pax Romana the
Roman peace and there have been
wonderful nations ours of course chief
among them obviously nation-states have
protected liberty in a way that that
other forms of government have not this
is the debate though and there are good
arguments on both sides of it so you
have Lindsey Graham kind of the
mouthpiece of those who favor a more
Tyrael foreign-policy Lindsey Graham is
furious at this decision he called in to
Fox & Friends this morning to voice his
displeasure with the president's move if
I didn't see Donald Trump's name on the
tweet I thought it was with the Obama's
rationale for getting out of Iraq so
here's what's going to happen this is
gonna lead to Isis Rian's nothing better
for Isis than the created conflict
between the Kurds and Turkey the Kurds
will now align with Assad because they
have nobody to count on because we
abandoned them so this is a big win for
a long and Assad a big win for Isis
I will do everything I can to sanction
Turkey if they step one foot in
northeastern Syria that will sever my
relationship with Turkey I think most of
the Congress feels that way I will do a
resolution the President to reconsider
this decision so he's coming out there
it's a big win for all these awful
people and it's just like Obama that's
what you saying he's saying it's may be
politically helpful in the short term
for a president Trump but in the long
run it's a disaster and really what he's
implying is that it's based on
insufficient determination to go out
there and fight our enemies and the the
brutal twist the dagger really going to
try to needle Trump is he saying that if
he didn't know any better he would have
thought that Obama had made this
decision this was an Obama s decision I
don't think that's quite fair I think
there's an important distinction I think
this is actually what Trump is getting
at Barack Obama ran as an anti-war
candidate and he ran and he said we got
to get out of Iraq even though as we
were as the 2008 campaign was going on
we were rewetting the war in Iraq
because of the surge Obama comes and
completely screws up our victory in Iraq
then he launched a bunch of new wars the
old joke was if I vote for John McCain
then we're gonna start another war in
the Middle East and they were right I
voted for John McCain and we started
more wars in the Middle East
so Obama launches all of these new wars
a war in Syria a new war in Libya most
notably I don't think President Trump is
falling into Obama's trap or at least
he's trying not to
think he's doing his best to avoid
Obama's trap so President Trump runs on
basically getting out of the Middle East
he ran on almost the same the same
platform he said we're gonna totally
destroy Isis then we're getting out of
the Middle East Oh what President Trump
saw is that Obama ran on that platform
and then he got mired in all of these
additional Wars and I think what Trump
is seeing is Iran on that platform I'm
gonna destroy Isis and then I'm getting
out of there I don't want my legacy to
look as bungled as Obama's legacy
because Obama looks weak and he looks
like a liar and he looks like he
couldn't accomplish what he sent out to
accomplish and Trump doesn't want that
he doesn't want history to look on him
that way so that's the Lindsey Graham
approach that's the Empire approach
that's what it's called the neocon
approach or what is referred to as
neocon Rand Paul has a different
approach Rand Paul called in he was
speaking with Neil Cavuto also on Fox
News I guess this is our foreign policy
has just made on Fox News and Twitter
that's that's where we are now in the
United States so Rand Paul calls in to
Neil Cavuto show and he is thrilled by
President Trump's decision he wants to
get out of Syria as quickly as possible
and he specifically goes out and lamb
bests the neo-cons
including Lindsey Graham we see the
Turks come in a lot of people in your
own party from Lindsey Graham Marco
Rubio Mitt Romney nikki Haley and on and
on and on says it's a travesty it's a
bad move it emboldened our enemies what
do you say well it sounds like you just
listed the neocon war caucus of the
Senate so yeah they always want to stay
at war they always think it's the best
answer but I would say this I think
President Trump recognized is what
President Reagan recognized
unfortunately too late and Beirut
leaving three or four hundred people in
an area that are vulnerable could lead
to catastrophe but also doesn't really
do anything to secure our national
security you know I'm kind of a believe
go big go big or go home
you know two or three people are just a
trip wire to get us drawn into something
and a tragedy probably but they aren't
enough to do anything in fact there may
be a couple of there may be dozens of
people at a time maybe it doesn't here
doesn't there they aren't enough to
deter anything and part of the
resolution of the war over there has to
be people who live over there the Turks
live over there the Syrians live over
there and he makes plenty of
points there what he's saying is just
like in the Beirut bombings the Beirut
attack that killed American troops even
if you only have a small number of
troops 100 or 200 or 300 troops there
they become a target and so even if it's
a small number of forces over there they
could bring you into a larger conflict
and what Rand Paul is saying is what are
we doing in Syria what's the purpose
we're just there waiting for something
to happen what is the end goal what is
victory look like why are we there what
and what he's really saying is why are
we an empire why are we going out there
and governing this Empire and tamping
down little conflicts and controlling
Syria and controlling different parts of
the world that have nothing to do with
our nation here in the United States
what's the point that's what he's asking
now what's the charitable way to put it
charitable way to put what his attacks
on the so-called neo-cons is there
people that want to empower the people
who want nationalism and that's what the
debate is even the neocon I try not to
use the neocon label to refer to those
who want to carpet-bomb their parts of
the Middle East because the term
neoconservative used to have a meaning
in it was the leftists of the 1960's who
became conservatives because they
realized the bankruptcy of leftism
Irving Kristol for instance bill
Crystal's father was in the neocon and
the term became just totally abused in
the 90s and 2000's it it was used in the
90s and 2000's the way that alt-right is
used now it was used just as a way to
smear anybody to the left or to the
right rather of say Hillary Clinton and
so I try not to use the term but that's
basically what it means and this is the
debate so President Trump has made clear
he supports nationalism and here is his
rationale for pulling out of Turkey or
for pulling out of Syria rather well I'm
not siding with anybody we've been in
Syria for many years you know Syria was
supposed to be a short term hit just a
very short term hit and we were supposed
to be in and out that was many many
years ago and we only have 50 people in
that area that's a small sector and I
don't want those 50 people hurt or
killed or anything I don't want anything
bad to happen our
people and I told that to president
erawan I said don't hurt any of our any
of our people get hurt big trouble I
will tell you this the we defeated Isis
so we defeated Isis and if Turkey does
anything to our troops we want to get
out I suspect that's what's going on I
suspect he knows Turkey is going to come
into northern Syria
he doesn't care enough to create some
big war with our ostensibly NATO allied
Turkey to prevent turkey from doing that
and he doesn't want us troops to be
sitting ducks because one or two US
troops get killed out there just one
just one US troop gets killed and all of
a sudden you were drawn into this huge
conflict and for what why why did that
with that US soldier have given his life
from what what is the purpose what are
we doing out there
so Trump goes on in those comments to
say his thesis which is we want to bring
our troops back home it's been many many
years it's been decades in many cases we
want to bring our troops back home and I
got elected on that right he did he's
been talking about this for years he's
been talking about this not just since
the campaign he's been talking about
this since 2013 in 2013 President Trump
tweeted out quote what will we get for
bombing Syria besides more debt and a
possible long-term conflict Obama needs
congressional approval then he tweets
that later what I'm saying is stay out
of Syria very explicit last year he
tried to pull out here's president troop
announcing that he's going to pull out
of Syria we spent and I was against it
from the beginning they try and say well
maybe not I was against it from the
beginning and by the way we're knocking
the hell out of Isis will be coming out
of Syria like very soon let the other
people take care of it now very soon
very soon we're coming out we're gonna
have a hundred percent of the Caliphate
as they call it sometimes referred to as
land taking it all back quickly quickly
but we're gonna be coming out of there
real soon gonna get back to our country
where we belong where we want to be that
was April 4th 2018 we didn't do it and
democracy is a fickle thing democracy on
one day the Conservatives say we want to
pull out of Syria we want to get out of
the Middle East we want to stay in our
homes we want to we don't want to go
overseas
the next day they say we need to invade
every single country on earth okay
public opinion shift so this I'm not
even criticizing the American people
that's how democracy works there are
good arguments to make on both sides and
if President Trump wants to avoid Barack
Obama's mistake then when it there isn't
a clear decision here and when public
opinion is going back and forth I think
there's really only one maxim he has to
follow which is sometimes even a wrong
decision is better than indecision I
think he understands that I mean he he
announces we're pulling out of Syria in
a year ago then he doesn't pull out of
Syria campaigns on it then he won't
campaign on he saw what happened to
Barack Obama for vacillating sometimes
even a wrong decision is better than
indecision at least our allies can can
go on decisiveness they might not like
the decision but at least they can plan
based on decisiveness that I think is
what we're seeing here moving on from
serious and momentous aspects of
pourraient foreign policy - hilarious
aspects of foreign policy I do have to
compliment President Trump on his
interactions with China for a second
Trump recently this a few days ago but I
had to get to it you know he's being
criticized for his phone call with
Ukraine which we are all read the
transcript of they might impeach him
over his phone call with Ukraine because
he said you crane should look into the
corruption of Joe Biden in in Ukraine
well the Biden's also got a crooked deal
out of China did Joe Biden's son hunter
flew on Air Force two flew with Joe
Biden to China and then shortly after
that meeting secured one and a half
billion dollars in financing from
Chinese government affiliated entities
why is it because hunter Biden is such
an expert on China I know he's not is
not even as good an expert on China as
he is on Ukrainian he doesn't know
anything about Ukraine it's obviously
grift it's obviously corruption because
his father was the vice president and so
they they're impeaching Trump a normal
politician would say listen well normal
politician would keep quiet about it
then a more trumpian politician might
come out and say hey listen weird
tracting from the big issue here I
didn't mean in the Ukraine call that I
was asking for a quid pro quo here's
what I meant he tried to explain himself
but then President Trump himself a
unique character in American politics
decides he's not gonna stay quiet he's
not going to defend himself he's going
to Double Down and so here is president
Trump's response on colluding with
foreign governments over the question of
the Biden's corruption well I would
think that if they were honest about it
that sort of major investigation into
the Vice it's a very simple answer they
should investigate devises because how
does a company that's newly formed and
all these companies that you look at and
by the way likewise China should start
an investigation into the Bible because
what happened to China is just about as
bad as what happened with with Ukraine
so I would say that President Solinsky
it were me I would recommend that they
start an investigation into the Biden's
because nobody has any doubt that they
weren't crooked that was a crooked deal
100% he had no knowledge of energy
didn't know the first thing about it all
of a sudden he's getting fifty thousand
dollars a month plus a lot of other
things nobody has any doubt and they got
rid of a prosecutor who was a very tough
prosecutor they got rid of him now
they're trying to make it the opposite
way but they get rid so if I were the
president I would certainly recommend
that of Ukraine absolutely the perfect
response to this and I guess it gets
back to our point sometimes the wrong
decision is better than indecision I
don't think this is the wrong decision I
think it's perfectly defensible to tell
Ukraine to look into corruption and
their own interference in the 2016
election and I think it's it's perfectly
right for President Trump to double down
on that because what's he gonna do he
could apologize and explain himself to
the press that's not going to get him
anywhere and there's no reason for him
to do it he doesn't know those people
one word of explanation and so what he
does is he goes out there and he he
makes a joke and and even Marco Rubio
who is obviously no particular fan of
the
Marco Rubio was asked about this
response from Trump and he just explains
to the press not president Trump's
remarks he explains to the press how
stupid the press is I don't know that's
a real request to him just needling the
press knowing that you guys are going to
get outraged by it he's gotten he's
pretty good at getting everybody fired
up and he's been doing that for a while
and the media responded right on right
on right on task you're one of the
loudest critics of China and it's human
rights abuses is it okay to say that I
don't think it's a real required to
connect he I think he did it to give you
guys I think he did it to provoke you to
ask me and others and get outraged by it
I said I mean he plays it like a violin
and every falls right into that's not a
real request of course I mean this is
this is now Senator Marco Rubio not
acting like a senator he's acting like
he's a panelist on special report you
know he's acting like a political
analyst and he's saying you you idiots
you if President Trump were going to use
the weight of the federal government to
leverage all of that and get a foreign
power and an adversarial power like
China to investigate his political
opponents if you were really doing that
he'd probably pick up the phone if you
were really doing that he maybe wouldn't
pick up the phone he'd get some
back-channel spy to go in and ask and he
would basically do it like Obama did you
do like Obama and Hillary and the
Democrats do but that's not what Trump
is doing he's forcing the press and
manipulating the press to expose their
own hypocrisy and it's so obvious the
one thing I like President Trump a lot
he's not subtle the guy's not exactly
nuanced okay big gold letters everything
he does and some had the press misses
this and and it requires Marco Rubio to
comment say oh you people you you
Schmucks what you can't even take plays
you people like a fiddle and he does and
believe it or not that's not even the
most ridiculous and outrageous thing
that the press has done of late you'll
see from NBC's Chuck Todd that just
totally showing their cards
as being divorced from reality and so so
in the tank that all they are as
propagandists for left we'll get to that
in a second then we'll get to a nice
note from Ellen DeGeneres's we're
actually a very nice nice note for the
culture which so rarely happens but
first I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and you too but I got to tell
you I know you're not gonna believe me
you've heard so many false promises from
so many people for so long but I
wouldn't lie to you and I am Telling You
the Daily wires long awaited app it's
finally here it is here and it is
fantastic go download it if you're a
subscriber you can access all of our
content including our articles and our
shows and a lot more there are a lot of
cool new features straight from the app
all access subscribers this is a new
tier it's a little bit more per month
but you get so much more you get our new
and exclusive discussion features where
they where you can interact directly
with our hosts and writers and other
special guests it is super cool I did a
discussion yesterday it was a lot of fun
it's like a reddit AMA and it's just
just so great to interact with people
the app is available on Apple and
Android so download it today become a
subscriber come join in on all the fun
head over to Daley wired.com you get
everything you get the leftist tears
tumblr now you get an app I don't know
if the app allows you to control the
flow of leftist tears or the temperature
of the leftist tears or anything like
that but the tears are still just as
delicious go to daily wire comm we'll be
right back with a lot more
speaking of craziness from the press
Chuck Todd on NBC who various times has
tried to portray himself as a more
moderate figure or more objective figure
just a journalist just going after the
facts Chuck Todd made one of the most
egregious statements the other day that
I saw this isn't the the clip that was
going around viral where he said Chuck
Todd came out and he said we're in a
national emergency this is a national
nightmare because President Trump talked
to the Ukrainian president though Chuck
Todd did that too and it was hysterical
and ridiculous but Chuck Todd was giving
doing an interview with John Brennan
John Brennan the old Obama Crone who has
become one of the most hysterical voices
of the anti-trump left and he has John
Brennan on John Brennan by the way
almost certainly complicit in a lot of
the wrongdoing that was going on in the
federal government's interference in the
2016 election trying to go after a
president Trump Chuck Todd goes on there
and he has the audacity the gall to say
that half of this country conservatives
in this country are divorced from
reality they don't believe reality and
Chuck Todd is the voice of the
mainstream media and the left but I
repeat myself he is the guardian and
custodian of reality here's Chuck Todd
well here's why we're here because there
is a distant we have we have two sets of
realities that live here there is a 40
percent of the country that is only
getting fed one one reality arguably 60
percent are getting what I would argue
is reality
so there's roughly half of the country a
little bit more he says that he
represents the majority of the country
the reality side of the country you know
the left and the Democrats and the
mainstream media they're there they
represent about 60% of the country I
mean Hillary still lost the election but
you know they but they're 60 percent
massive majority of the country and then
you have the Conservatives and they are
40% of the country and they just they
just don't get reality they just don't
have any connection to reality
let me put that in stalker terms the
left which believes that men can just
magically become women by wishing it to
be so the left which believes that the
Sun Monster and the weather are going to
destroy humanity within 10 years there
will be a mass extinction event that's
the that's the phrase that's been going
around the left which believes based on
nothing the president from colluded with
Russia to rig the 2016 election in in
the face of all evidence to the contrary
and a two and a half year 30 million
dollar investigation the let that's the
left
they are the custodians of reality and
then the people who believe that there
are two biological sexes the people who
don't think that humanity will be wiped
off the face of the earth
those people they don't have a
connection to reality let me just I'm
just I'm just trying to work through
this in my head the left which believes
that unborn babies in the womb who have
all their little limbs and all their
little fingers and they look like babies
and they sound like babies and by the
way they are babies that they're not
babies that they're just a random clump
of cells there are the custodians of
reality
but the right which believes that babies
are babies they're not they're not the
custodians of reality they're
disconnected from reality the left which
so often denies reality itself denies
objective truth which we hear from
campus to campus that there is no truth
there's your truth in my truth that
everything is simply a matter of
preference everything is simply a matter
of will they are the custodians of
reality but the right which believes an
objective truth which extol the virtues
of objective reality they have no
connection this is exactly backwards to
talk Chuck Todd Chuck Todd is talking to
John Brennan one of the most prolific
and famous liars and hysterics in the
federal government and he is talking to
him about they understand reality
this is what I mean when I say the left
gets things exactly backwards it's not
like Chuck Todd is a little bit off it's
not like he's just missing the mark a
little bit he is getting it exactly
backwards and he's getting it exactly
backwards from his from his own position
Chuck Todd says he's a journalist he's
here he's concerned about the truth he
is behaving is nothing but a
propagandist for the left nothing but a
propagandist for the Democratic Party
nothing but a propagandist for people
who want to overturn this presidential
election how often if we played the
montage on this show of people talking
about Trump's in a corner the walls are
closing and impeachment is coming he
colluded with Russia that didn't work he
colluded with Ukraine even though
they're mortal enemies vehicle okay he
did all these things those people who
lie to you 24/7 they have the gall not
just to keep lying to you through their
teeth but to go on television and say we
are the custodians of reality and you
guys have no connection to reality
that's the media folks that's the left
and that is why as I've learned and we
learned again in recent weeks you
shouldn't believe everything you read in
the newspapers and you shouldn't believe
everything you see on TV and you should
ignore people like Chuck Todd who are
lying through their teeth and just keep
on keeping on this is a degree of
political fantasy the check Todd is
talking about that really boggles the
mind and that's why I'm so glad that
there is a there was a rejoinder to this
because we are increasingly told by the
left anyone who disagrees with you on
anything is evil is stupid is is not
worth speaking to as deplorable as
irredeemable as all these terrible
things by the way we don't believe that
about the left we on the right think
that the left is just wrong it just get
it wrong they get it backwards they get
it they're missing something I don't
think they're all evil they're just
really wrong yes some people are evil
some people are evil on both sides there
are very terrible people on both sides
to paraphrase a statement of the
presidents but the left really believes
that about us increasingly and here's
the evidence
Ellen DeGeneres was in a Dallas Cowboys
game she was there over the weekend she
was there hanging out with her friend
George W Bush yes she has been friends
with George Bush for a while and they
were in the owners box at the Cowboys
game and they're watching the game they
had a nice time and a picture went
around the Internet of Ellen having a
good time with George Bush the left went
crazy the left said you're not allowed
to be friends with people on the other
side of the aisle here here is one guy
Ben Norton who is somebody who has a
blue checkmark for some reason he tweets
out I'm friends with George Bush boasts
Ellen saying it's good to have friends
with different views but this isn't a
matter of views it's a matter of crimes
Bush is a war criminal with the blood of
1 million Iraqis on his hands he should
be in prison what war crimes did George
Bush commit what can't name them we he
was a war president that's true no he's
not a war criminal this guy Ben Norton
goes on it's one thing to be friends
with people with different political
views it's something totally different
to be friends with a mass murderer mass
murderer who ruined millions of lives
destroyed thousands of families and made
children orphans and destabilized an
entire region of the world exclamation
point this is what they always do on the
Left they say oh yeah I'm totally
open-minded I can be friends with
different people that's fine to be
friends with conservatives but you can't
be friends with actual conservatives
it's always the butt and then it's
always what follows they say look I'm
friends with plenty of conservatives I
just am NOT friends with people who want
to protect innocent life and support a
traditional definition of marriage and
think that we should secure our border
and support enforcing our laws and think
we should have lower taxes but other
than those guys I'm friends with a lot
of conservatives they just they just say
they're not president and it can't say
they're friends with any actual
conservatives they're just friends with
conservatives in theory the left loves
humanity the left just doesn't like
humans very much another leftist Shaun
King you know he's the black lives
matter guy although I think he's in
trouble with black lives matter because
he's a complete fraud so he's gotten a
little kickback from black lives matter
he tweets out quote it appears many of
you may be genuinely unaware that
insiders said nobody worked harder to
get Brett Kavanaugh on the Supreme Court
than George W Bush he fought for a
concert
amendment to ban gay marriage and they
were act war which was based on a lie
killed millions so the big the big issue
that Jean King has with George Bush is
he supported Brett Kavanaugh perhaps the
most milquetoast lawyer in the history
of the country to be on the Supreme
Court you can't be friends with somebody
who supports the president having a
different president having the right to
put a Supreme Court justice on the court
that's it that's the line and that's
increasingly what the left tells us
thankfully fortunately Ellen had a
different point of view Charlotte Jones
Portia was talking to and George W Bush
and then in front of us was the tallest
man in the world so I've got to say when
we were invited I was you know I was
aware that I was gonna be surrounded
with people from very different views
and beliefs and I'm not talking about
politics I was rooting for the Packers
and get this everybody and the Cowboys
suite was rooting for the Cowboys and so
I had to hide my cheese hat in Portia's
purse and don't get me wrong I I like
the Cowboys I love the Cowboys I love
all the Village People as a matter of
fact but during the game they showed a
shot of George and me laughing together
and so people were upset they thought
why is a gay Hollywood liberal sitting
next to a conservative Republican
president didn't even notice I'm holding
the brand new iPhone 11 and but a lot of
people were mad and they did what people
do when they're mad they tweet and but
here's one tweet that I loved this
person says Ellen and George Bush
together makes me have faith in America
again here's okay I'm friends with
George Bush in fact I'm friends with a
lot of people who don't share the same
beliefs that I have we're all different
and I think that we've forgotten that
that's okay that we're all different an
excellent excellent point from Ellen who
I've always really gotten a kick out of
I think she's just a terrific
entertainer and she's she's pretty funny
but she's just a great kind of showbiz
figure and she comes from a little bit
more of an old-school
an old-school of Hollywood in an old
school of politics she's as liberal as
they come but she tolerates people
having other opinions she tolerates the
complexity of life
and she even enjoys the diversity and
complexity of life which is something
that as a conservative I certainly do I
think that's one of the greatest values
that conservatives have which brings me
I just want to mention this before we go
today - some of the hypocrisy on the
impeachment because we are told on this
impeachment is that President Trump
asked a favor of the Ukrainian president
and it would help him politically and
this is very bad and we're not sure what
law this violates exactly but it's very
bad and we need to impeach him for it so
transcript just came out
I think Tucker Carlson found this comes
out from 2000 from the Bill Clinton
Presidential Library the year 2000 right
before a presidential election Bill
Clinton is having a phone call with Tony
Blair who is the Prime Minister of
Britain and Tony Blair he says to Tony
Blair I think more than anything else
let me ask you something on a much more
mundane issue yesterday I met with some
cabinet members and Rodney Slater said
we put some more ideas down to resolve
the airport dispute with British Airways
u.s. air in American Airlines would you
take another look at that and see if we
can get it done so this is a very minor
issue that affects Great Britain in the
United States Tony Blair says I'm not
completely familiar with that he doesn't
even know about the issue Clinton goes I
know you're up to your ears and other
things but we've been dealing with this
for years and it's sort of a big issue
here Rodney told me he put some more
stuff down on the table in a political
season it would be big over here to get
this open sore resolved if you could
have somebody take a look at it I've
never been seen a more agitate he's
trying to get it solved Blair says sure
I'll take a look
imagine if Trump use the words in a
political season just before an election
year I need this favor I mean this is
explicitly asking for a favor Blair says
yeah I'll take a look I don't care that
Clinton did this I don't think it
matters whatsoever I think this is this
is what politics is it shows that there
is a little more complexity to these
issues and the people clamoring for
impeachment now because Trump did
something far less clear than what clean
and what I think virtually every
American president has done at some
point or another there they're failing
it it's not that they're wrong about the
other guy it's not that they're wrong
about Trump it's not that they're wrong
about seeing corruption in the
government's not that they're wrong
about not liking how politics is because
politics is very ugly it's like that old
quote from Otto von Bismarck it's best
not to see how the sausages are made
it's this is something that's true of
laws and is true of sausages it's true
of meat that's not to see how it gets
made just see it at the end there is
great complexity here this is on
everything from getting an airport
dispute resolved in in the US and
Britain to the u.s. position in northern
Syria there is great complexity here we
all lack a lot of knowledge we would all
do to have a bit more humility and most
importantly we would do to have a bit
more humility and grace with regard to
our fellow Americans to take a lead from
Ellen DeGeneres here and not say as
Chuck Todd says that half the country as
is completely lost but we can't even
have a conversation with them they're
totally lost we can't reach them ignore
them dismiss them don't dismiss them
even if you think half the country is
wrong talk to them make some arguments
have a conversation with them don't
think that half the country like Hillary
Clinton does is deplorable and
irredeemable reality is much more
complex much more wonderfully diverse
then hard-line ideologues would have us
believe a good note to end on Ellen
DeGeneres says be kind I would add to
that be humble that's our show
I'm Michael nose this is the Michael
Nolt show I'll see you again tomorrow
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel why
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everyone its Andrew Klavan and host
of the Andrew Clavin show is a debate
among conservatives over whether Trump
is doing the right thing by pulling out
of Syria which tells you something it
tells you there's a debate among
conservatives not so much on the left
where it's all 888 orange man bad no
matter what he does he'll talk about it
on the Andrew Klavan show I'm